the u.s navy is now training sailors on
gender pronouns
that's a big priority
let's read from the washington free
beacon before we pull that video up the
navy's training its members to create a
safe space we've heard that before by
using proper gender pronouns in a new
instructional video modeled after a
children's show huh there you go
the official training video is meant to
empathize
emphasize quote the importance of using
correct pronouns as well as polite
etiquette when you may not be sure of
someone's pronouns according to the navy
which last month published the video
online
i hadn't seen it i did now
the defense visual information
distribution service touts the video as
quote an official u.s navy video posted
by air force staff sergeant john
vannucchi okay
so let's just take a look at the video
we're gonna play it i'm gonna react
provide some commentary i think you need
to see you think about the navy you
think about what they do what they
should be doing let's take a look at
what they're focused on right now
let's go
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i'm kanji and i use chi
herb pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns
what is a pronoun a pronoun is how we
identify ourselves apart from our name
and it's also how people refer to us in
conversations using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity okay so
here i am already just started and i'm
already my blood pressure has risen
first of all why do they model it after
children's show why do i feel like a
five-year-old in kindergarten watching
this and why do they need the sailors to
feel that way what is going on have i
completely lost my mind
i'm watching this i see it why
it reminded me of blue's clues you guys
remember that cartoon before i got on
air i said what was that blue dog who
was always a lesson involved why are
they infantilizing
people in the navy
can you imagine your job is to serve and
protect you gotta sit and watch this
video come on okay i'm gonna continue
tyler i'm gonna do this a lot throughout
this video so gotta be prepared
acceptance we're gonna continue with the
video if it's a signal of acceptance and
respect how do we go about creating a
safe space for everybody safe that's a
good question a really good way to do
that is to use inclusive language
instead of saying something like hey
guys you can say hey everyone or hey
team
yeah and now that you say that another
way that we could show that we're allies
and that we accept
everybody is to maybe include our
pronouns in our emails or like we just
did introduce ourselves using our
pronouns okay stop
first of all hey guys i use that for
everyone all the time
i i don't say you know i mean you walk
into him hey guys or hey guys what's up
now you can't say that you can't say hey
guys stop it this there's no better way
to say this this is a mentally unhinged
conversation
this is a mentally unhinged conversation
you're going to have to open an email
now people are going to have to define
themselves as he her
she him whatever it
maybe i'll just use it from now on it
simplifies everything maybe i'm the
monster from stranger things because i
identify that way
what is going on okay what is going on
tyler can you do me a favor i need to
skip to 2 20 in the video this is one of
my favorite parts
this woman in the video seems pleasant
she describes an encounter
that she had with someone who didn't
want to use the demanded pronouns that
person objected and said it's my freedom
to not do this and she had a reaction to
it let's play her reaction to it 220.
pronouns and somebody was disagreeing
with
how different people
see themselves as different pronouns and
the argument was if you look like a
female then it's chi her because that's
what's normal and if you make me call
you something else then you're
infringing on my rights
and i i was really taken aback by the
comment and i really wasn't sure
how to respond and the only thing i
could really think quickly to say was
it's not about you at all
and
it's mostly and ultimately about respect
it is about respect so she could fathom
she couldn't fathom that someone might
say
i don't want to do that i don't want to
play this fictional game with you i
don't want to play
house what's going on we're not three
we're not three years old so if i walk
in here today to do my show and i
announce when i walk into everybody that
i'm a kitten
i'm a kitten and i start meowing and
hissing and scratching it happens
sometimes i've been known to scratch a
thing or two a post or two shall we say
but if i do that everybody here has to
call me a kitten
has to treat me like okay this is a
kitten or i'm not being respected this
is the world we live in now let's think
about it
let's think about it and what happens
behaviorally if i start just let's say i
just pause the mic push it aside
go for a little round of scratching
anybody got any catnip
people are laughing these guys are
laughing but seriously this is where we
are
and and if you don't oblige if you don't
oblige you are disrespecting me okay
so i started by saying this is mentally
unhinged some people might have found
that extreme this is mentally unhinged
you can call yourself whatever you want
you don't then get to demand that
everybody play that game
that's what they're doing now let's get
back to the focal point now you could
watch this video let's say it wasn't for
the us navy
let's say it just existed for within a
company
it would be bad enough right we would be
sitting here and covering this video
this absolute and complete insanity this
breakdown of facts and and just absence
of mental sanity we would be covering it
regardless regardless but then you have
to remind yourself this is for the us
navy
so let's remind ourselves what the us
navy is supposed to do let's go to the
website how about that navy.com they
have a mission statement on the bottom
right of the website i pulled it from
here
and this is what it says
to recruit train equip and organize to
deliver combat-ready naval forces to win
conflicts
and wars
while maintaining security and
deterrence through sustained forward
presence that is what the us navy is
supposed to be doing
they are supposed to be combat ready
they are supposed to be focused one of
the hardest jobs in the world right we
all say those who serve and protect
those who serve and protect these people
have to be at the ready
to fight a war and hopefully
to win that's why they're there
they're not there to make you feel good
about what pronoun they use
this is terrifying
my friend jesse kelly always says we're
gonna lose a major war when he used to
say that on twitter i used to laugh it
was funny he would put you know that
comment above
it's not so funny anymore it's true
it is true
you have other nations ramping up and
this is what we're doing
this is what we're doing
they had to sit and watch this video can
you imagine you sit you watch this video
you leave that room you're deflated
you're like what am i even doing here
i would if i were there i'd be losing
passion in the mission oh these people
how do you take that job seriously when
the people in charge don't take your job
seriously they're gonna send you in to
fight but first you've got to watch an
instructional video about what to call
someone so that they feel comfortable
and they don't go home crying that day
if you go home crying that day
sorry to say if you go home crying that
day because someone used the wrong
pronoun you better get out of the navy
you better get out of the navy you
better step back and put somebody in
there who isn't hurt so easily these
people are there to fight wars
wake up america
wake up
so this woke stink you know when you see
like i've never personally maybe you
have tyler i've never been sprayed by a
skunk
lucky in that capacity when you get
sprayed by a skunk have you been sprayed
by skunk ever thankfully not okay knock
on wood so we lucky we share that knock
on what tyler's gonna leave go home
today go on a little trip over the
weekend and be like you will never guess
what happened yep it's coming because
now that we said it hasn't happened to
you it will
you get sprayed by a skunk and the stink
is everywhere right there's an episode
of curious george my son watches george
gets sprayed by a skunk they have to
like wash him with tomato juice it's a
whole big thing well the woke stink is
everywhere now
it's not just you know
in your city
at the local theater it's in your kid's
school
and now it's in the military the problem
is is that when this stuff gets into the
military we're gonna wind up with a
major national security threat this is a
national security threat the fact that
this is being prioritized in the
military
and these men and women are like they
have to shrink behind a table and watch
a little video this is horrible
you want to show them the video show a
video that fires them up
that makes them feel like they're ready
to go out there
ready to make something happen they're
at the ready they're strong they're
fierce
that's what they should be watching not
this nonsense
and why is it modeled again after a
children's video come on
2022 you're making it hard man i want to
love you i want to support you you're
making it hard
so when i saw this i said to myself
first of all we're in big trouble
tyler brought up a great point before
the show he talked about china vermont
tell everybody what you shared with me
before the show uh four days ago china
just launched their largest warship to
date this video came out two days ago
four days ago china launched their
warship it's their largest aircraft
carrier to date uh nextgen technology uh
high defense it's it's basically
rivaling the us now they don't have as
many as we do but to to the point
they're moving ahead they're preparing
for battle and we're putting out things
so i wonder if in china
they're shown videos like this let's
make up a video modeled after a child
child's television show and let's sit
everyone out that we want to be prepared
for combat and let's have them do that
my guess would be no
we better wake up and we better wake up
real fast it's getting scary it's
getting dangerous what was once funny is
now scary and dangerous
so when i saw this i you know i had my
my reaction and then i said you know
what we got to get this guy out of the
white house because
this trickles from from the top down
right
leaderships or the or the absence of
leadership trickles from the top down
joe biden is a problem the people around
maybe not jill biden because i don't
think he knows where he is most of the
time sad to say very sad reality but the
people around him
big problem they think this stuff is
cool
they think this stuff is cool
side note before we move on to
leadership if you wanted to actively
destroy a country if you wanted to
actively destroy a country
what would you do
what would you do would you do
maybe maybe you would make the military
feel real small
maybe you would have them spend their
time watching woke videos
modeled after children's television
shows instead of getting ready for
combat
maybe you'd be worried about instilling
a mandatory experimental vaccine and
discharging people who didn't comply i'm
just saying
things sound when people say that
destruction is intentional you have to
sit back and ask yourself is it
and what would you do it's a question
what would you do if you wanted to
actively destroy a country and then
think about what's happened in the last
two years you can't help but say what's
going on here
just a question if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]